وداعا للعبث الفرنسي في افريقيا.
القارة السمراء تطرد الفرنسيين
الى غير رجعة. ما عاد هناك مجال
للاستعمار. الدول تحررت وشعوبها
تستقل بسيادتها. نعم. لقد
اعلنتها الماما افريكا. هنا لا
مقام للفرنسيين ومرحبا بالدب
الروسي. لتصبح موسكو الشريك
الامني الاول للافارقة. لقد طفح
الكيل وبلغ سيل الزباه ولم يبق
في قوس صبر من زاع. دولة بعد
اخرى تقول لا لفرنسا لقد حان وقت
الحصاد واجتثاث الاشواك الفرنسية
من المزارع الافريقية. عن سقوط
المعاقل الفرنسية في افريقيا
نتحدث قصة بقية. فرنسا تتذوق
العلقم الذي اذاقته لافريقيا. من
شيغاك الى ماكرون فقدت فرنسا
موطئ دمها في افريقيا. ما تعيشه
فرنسا اليوم في افريقيا اسوأ
مرحلة في علاقتها بمستعمراتها
السابقة في القارة السمراء. فمن
كان يصدق ان تجرأ دولة مثل ما لي
على طرد السفير الفرنسي من
اراضيها. هي ليست توترات بين دول
افريقيا وفرنسا ولكنه تحول
تاريخي يطال كل القارة
الافريقية. هذه البلدان تنتفض
لاسباب وحسابات داخلية بعد ان
الافارقة الاهمية الاستراتيجية
لبلدانهم فهي كنوز ثمينة تسلط
عليها الاستعمار الفرنسي. ومن
خلفه الاستعمار الاوروبي فكل
العواصم الاوروبية تدق ابواب
القارة السمراء. بل ان من يخطب
ود الماما افريكا يأتون من الصين
والولايات المتحدة وروسيا حتى ان
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن استعجل
قمة امريكية افريقية في ديسمبر
الماضي. لكن الفرنسي لم يقدروا
جيدا الكنز الثمين الذي تسلطوا
عليه وكانها جوهرة في يد فحام
والحرب في اوكرانيا لا تبتعد عن
التحولات في افريقيا افصحت دول
القارة في مواقفها وفي خيارات
التصويت داخل الامم المتحدة بشأن
اوكرانيا انها لم تعد منطقة نفوذ
غربية وان لم تقفز للانزلاق تحت
مظلات روسيا والصين. ولا يختلف
حال افريقيا عن حال مناطق عديدة
في العالم من مجموعة الاوبيك بلس
الى مجموعة البريكس وغيرها من
بلدان العالم. ليكتشف حلف الناتو
ان القارة السمراء تقع في حدود
نفوذه في العالم لكنها تتهادى
شيئا فشيئا نحو الاحضان الروسية
والصينية. فالصين تقترب لتكون
الشريك التجاري الاول للقارة
الافريقية. وروسيا هي الشريك
الامني الاقوى وفرنسا مع حلف
الناتو في مهب الريح. وها هم
يفهمون بسهولة ان روسيا جاءت
وبكل بساطة لتقطف محصولهم حيث
ظلت فرنسا تزرعه طوال عقود. هنا
تتحجر الالسن لتبدو وباريس
متلعثمة في تفسير هذا الفشل في
مجموعة دول الساحل الخمس. ونقصد
ما لي وبوركينا فاسو وتشاد
والنيجر وموريتانيا. عدوى طرد
الفرنسيين تنتقل من ما لي الى
بوركينا فاسو. وذلك طرد غرفة
عمليات القوات سبر والتي يتراوح
اعدادها ما بين ثلاثمائة وخمسين
الى اربعمائة من القوات الخاصة
وهي المنفذ الرئيسي لاغلب
الضربات النوعية الفرنسية ضد
قيادات الجماعات المسلحة
بالمنطقة. قرار الطرد لم يكن من
الحكومة فقط. فها هي المظاهرات
تتجدد في العاصمة وجادوجو ضد
الوجود العسكري الفرنسي في
البلاد. مع شعارات مناهضة لباريس
وتنكيس للعلم الفرنسي. لكن في
الوقت الذي تطرد فيه بوركينا
فاسو الجنود الفرنسيين من
اراضيها فتحت اذرعها لروسيا
وبسطت لقوات فوجنر السجاد الاحمر
للدوس على الاراضي البوركينية
واخذ مكان القوات الفرنسية هناك
اي انها استبدلت فرنسا بروسيا.
نعم افلحت روسيا في ركوب موجة
العداء لباريس فقد شوهدت اعلام
روسية اكثر من مرة ترفرف في سماء
العاصمة وجادوجو ونشرت قواتها
الخاصة فاجنر في هذا البلد
الافريقي. الامر ليس الا ان
بوركينا فاسو التحقت بما لي،
فالغت الاتفاقات مع باريس وكسرت
المواثيق والعهود. لان الفرنسيين
اثبتوا فشلهم في وضع حد لنشاط
الجماعات المسلحة في القارة
وخاصة في منطقة الساحل والصحراء
رغم مرور سنوات عدة على بدء
باريس حربها ضد هذه لكن الطامة
الكبرى جاءت بارتكاب قوات باريس
جرائم في حق المدنيين بالقارة
الافريقية وكما يقول المثل
حاميها حراميها لكن هذا الحامي
يزيد الطين بلة فيقتل القتيل
ويمشي في جنازته. لتدق دول
الساحل الافريقي اخر مسمار في
النعش الفرنسي. وما جرى في ما لي
من تحولات متسارعة هو النموذج
الاكثر وضوحا لهذا الانهيار
الفرنسي مستعمراتها التقليدية اذ
اعتبرت السلطة الجديدة المدعومة
روسيا هذا الوجود الفرنسي
انتهاكا صارخا للسيادة الوطنية
ومحاولة لتقسيم ما لي ودعما
للجماعات الارهابية. فبدأت
بسلسلة من الاجراءات لفك هذا
الارتباط وفسخ كل الاتفاقيات
الدفاعية مع باريس والمطالبة
بانسحاب كل القوات الفرنسية
منها. وهو ما تم فعليا في الفين
واثنين وعشرين اي ان هيمنة فرنسا
على مستعمراتها الافريقية
السابقة قد دخلت مرحلة الافول.
ولا رجع. فرنسا واجهت صدام
الافيال. واخذت تخسر رويدا رويدا
اوراقها كافة. والامر باختصار ان
افريقيا لم تعد تحتمل وجودا
عسكريا استعماريا قديما او جديدا
على اراضيها. فحتى النيجر
المتمسكة بعلاقات متقدمة مع
فرنسا قد لا تقبل اعداد جديدة من
الجنود الفرنسيين المغادرين
لبوركينا فاسو. الاستعباد
الاقتصادي. هو نوع من النهب
الفرنسي الممنهج اذ فرضت فرنسا
عملة الفرنك الافريقي على اربع
عشرة دولة افريقية. ما جعلها
مرتبطة عضويا للاقتصاد الفرنسي
وخمسة وثمانين بالمائة من
اقتصاديات هذه الدول تحت رحمة
البنك المركزي الفرنسي حتى خمسين
بالمئة من احتياطاتها مودعة في
البنوك الفرنسية اي نحو خمسمائة
مليار دولار سنويا من الارباح
والعوائد القادمة من افريقيا.
وفي عام الفين وتسعة عشر استبدلت
بعض الدول الافريقية هذا الفرنك
الفرنسي بعملة الايكو المستقلة
عن باريس. انه استقلال الاقتصادي
يا سادة. سياسة النهب الفرنسي
سبق ان اعلنتها رئيسة الوزراء
الايطالية حاليا بقولها.
Belin?
Il Vujoud il اخر جندي من
الاحتلال الفرنسي لبوركينا فاسو
تم انزال علم فرنسا للمرة
الاخيرة. لكن ما يحز في نفوس
الفرنسيين ان العلم الروسي والذي
اخذ مكانهم. فهل تحتضن القارة
السمراء احتلالا جديدا باستقبال
الروس ام انه مجرد تعاون امني
لفترة